il
bonsoir à tous
derrière moi se trouve une photo de mes
parents papa maman
la tempête a été forte les vagues
énormes et dévastatrice ce 9 novembre 84
un fauteuil est entré dans votre vie
vous êtes de rester debout fière et fort
votre pudeur à ne jamais avoir voulu
montrer votre douleur et touchante
je vous aime j'ai 47 ans je vis depuis
30 ans dans ce drôle d'engin un engin
qui vous fait forcément voir la vie
d'une autre manière
alors pourquoi une photo de mes parents
tout simplement parce que ce sont eux
qui m'ont construit dans tous les sens
du terme et que cette photo fait partie
d'un projet s'appelle lettre à un ami et
qui consiste à photographier les gens
que j'aime les personnes auxquelles je
suis le plus attaché avec ou dans ce
fauteuil lors d'une rencontre je leur
explique le projet et je leur demande de
d'imaginer quel est notre relation ils
sont parfois surpris parfois gênés en
tout cas jamais indifférent chacun prend
le temps de réfléchir à son ressenti
avec avec ce fauteuil roulant et son
propriétaire
et puis après quelques temps chacun
propose une idée une idée que je mets en
scène
puis vient le temps de la photo ou comme
un imbécile je donne moyens de transport
aux gens que j'ai photographié ce qui
simplifie pas les choses parce que
pendant ce temps là je suis allongé par
terre je suis assis sur une chaise en
plein milieu d'une route ça donne lieu à
des à des situations assez cocasses et
puis une fois que cette photo est fait
en regard de cette photo je leur ai
écrit un texte une lettre une lettre à
un ami qui est le nom de ce projet en
voici quelques exemples
patrick nous étions jeunes et à
mobylette nous distribuions des journaux
pour me faire quelques sous c'était une
autre époque ma mobylette s'est
transformée mais la folie est resté en
copain d'enfance aussi david il ne plaît
depuis toujours à me rendre en carrosse
dans votre château mille roses quel joli
nom pour une bâtisse est un vin si
subtile vous avez à la fois le sens du
ridicule et un vrai sens de l'amitié
auriez-vous cependant l'amabilité de ne
pas essuyer vos pompes sûrement moyen de
transport jammes dis toi que ton papa en
kryte le deuxième du nom est un drôle de
rigolo ce fauteuil orange on peut en
rire tu es mal tu es ma complice soit ma
fille alors pourquoi cette idée
tout simplement parce que la
photographie est ma passion que j'aurais
aimé en faire mon travail parce que
l'écriture est quelque chose qui me
libère et puis enfin parce que la
relation aux autres
les relations humaines sont quelque
chose qui compte énormément pour moi
ensuite parce que la position assise
confesse un certain regard
un certain détachement elle permet de
développer un sens de l'observation aigu
je dirais même un sens demain team aussi
parce que je me suis rendu compte que
quoi que je fasse et où que j'aille ma
différence me permettait de créer de la
relation et puis certainement aussi
parce que je j'ai dû inconsciemment
vouloir témoigner sur le handicap en
faisant passer le message que cette
épreuve pouvait susciter un intérêt
jean paul sartre disait je ne suis pas
responsable de ce que la vie m'a fait
je suis responsable de ce que je vais
faire de ce que la vie m'a fait en
physique la résilience
on en a parlé tout à l'heure la
résilience et la capacité pour une pièce
de métal a retrouvé après un choc
sa forme initiale en psychologie on
parle de résilience pour un être qui est
capable après un choc après un
traumatisme pour sa capacité à se
reconstruire et se ne pas tomber dans la
dépression
la résilience
on dit que la résilience serait rendue
possible par des expériences
structurante de l'enfance ou par là la
réflexion par la parole
en ce qui me concerne je crois avoir
trouvé cette force tout simplement dans
le regard de mes parents ils vont donner
de la confiance de l'énergie de
l'énergie positive
un optimisme débordant et je crois que
ça a été pour moi la meilleure façon
d'affronter cette épreuve
ensuite j'ai été sportif de haut niveau
avant mon accident et jeu pratiqué le
volley ball et je crois que la pratique
de ce sport est aussi la personne qui me
l'a enseigné qui s'appelle luc de la ba
qui a été comme un second père pour moi
a permis de trouver la force et puis ça
m'a permis aussi de me forger un mental
de gagnant certainement
et puis il ya eu des personnages de ma
jeunesse comme man who qui est là ce
soir et laurent laurent alors du coup
j'en au but de montrer laurent il est où
laurent t ou laurent
laurent on a fait cette photo il ya
quinze jours sur la plage en bretagne
comme quoi il fait pas toujours un temps
pourri chez nous je ne sais si un seul
mot existe pour définir cette équation
insoluble et rigolote une force
magnétique un champ fusionnelle de
l'amour en folie de livrer 100 km malo
lot chéri mon frère mon pote de toujours
je pense pouvoir dire que mon accident
finalement n'a été qu'un rebondissement
après quelques mois passés à l'hôpital
trois mois contre l'avis des médecins
je suis ressorti de l'hôpital
j'ai passé mon bac j'ai fait des études
de droit tout travers et puis je me suis
finalement lancé avec gourmandise dans
la vie philippe genne à te retrouver sur
les chemins de mon enfance quand tu
bandits de ce fauteuil sur cette plage
j'y vois un hymne à la joie à
l'optimisme et la victoire
carpostal île d'oléron juillet 2010
alors certes je ne vais pas vous faire
croire que la vie en fauteuil roulant et
est aisé ou facile quand cela vous
arrive ce ce n'est pas noir
ce n'est pas gris plutôt c'est noir ou
blanc il est sur un fil en équilibre et
vous tombez d'un côté ou de l'autre
dans la vie j'ai l'habitude de dire que
plus on prend des claques dans la gueule
et puis on avance il se trouve que je
les prises assez tôt et que ça va
obliger à réfléchir autrement
et comment se projeter dans la vie quand
vous êtes frustrés sens de savoir quand
vous vivez des frustrations perpétuelle
est bien avec le temps j'ai compris que
l'afrique eu de la frustration
finalement est une invitation à trouver
le bonheur en soi et que elle vous
permet de elle vous permet de ne garder
que le nécessaire que l'essentiel que le
vital pour trouver la force de vivre
denis mon ami
si ce désir est lui aussi
c'est ce que la frustration veux dire
mon ami denis même si cela ne se voit
pas lui c'est la vue qu'il perd et je
crois que comme moi il a compris que
l'essentiel c'était l'urgence de vivre
l'urgence de partager
l'urgence d'échangés l'urgence des
différents de le montrer de l'assumer et
je vais donc vous lire une lettre à
denis même si je porte un boulet je sais
que je n'ai pas le monopole du fil à la
patte
je lis dans ton regard un monde
incertain et de souffrance ton
insatiable soif de découverte
ta liberté d'agir et de penser nous
réunissent une affection profonde ne
relie à toi tu alors quand vous ne
pouvez pas faire ce que les autres font
eh bien il faut réussir à trouver une
autre manière de le faire
moi je crois vraiment que c'est la
photographie qui m'a permis de voir les
choses d'une autre manière c'est le cas
de le dire et je crois que la
sensibilité que j'ai perdu dans mes
membres finalement je crois avoir
décuplé dans mon regard et puis quand
vous êtes frustré il ya une chose très
importante qui est essentiel c'est le
rire c'est l'humour c'est la dérision
c'est être capable de rire de ce que
l'on vit et être capable de le vivre
pleinement
m
alors ça m'a si je vous dis ça c'est que
le handicap permet de de tout voir
vraiment d'une autre manière
sincèrement même le corps des femmes
imaginez mesdames que la première chose
que je vois chez vous quand je vous
rencontre c'est votre poitrine ça quand
même de la gueule
le nez dans un décolleté si je vous dis
ça c'est que la sexualité en fait et le
handicap c'est quelque chose qui
intéresse énormément les gens alors j'ai
toujours été surpris de ça mais la
première question qu'on me pose vous
n'allez pas le croire mais c'est vrai
très souvent et très rapidement c'est de
savoir si je peux la première fois qu'on
m'a dit dis domjan fille tu peux je peux
je peux quoi est ce que tu peux vas-y
dit je peux quoi c'est un peu gênant
est ce que est ce que tu peux il peut
faire l'amour a dit bah oui oui oui ça
m'embête un peu de te demander ça mais
oui froid alors je vous rassure mesdames
ça sera pas chérie chéri
prends moi debout contre la commode
c'est pas tellement de boue c'est la
commode qui m'embête
ça sera pas non plus j'ai super envie
que tu m'as tes patins à roulettes que
tu te suspendant liste du plafond moi je
me mets à quatre pattes là sur la
moquette du suspens et e cheval mais
même là les indiens se sera pas ça ça
sera pas ça je le rassure mais ça sera
beaucoup plus subtil ça sera beaucoup
plus touchant ça sera beaucoup plus en
air en énervant ça sera beaucoup plus
enivrant je vais arrêter là parce que je
m'excite moi même
alors cela m'a donné l'occasion de faire
une image puisque c'est intéressant
monde que j'aime assez regardé cette
jeune femme quand je lui parlais du
projet mais qu'elle m'a dit
immédiatement tout de suite
hu il faudrait trouver une gonzesse
sous-entendant que c'était elle qui
accepterait de faire des trucs chouettes
en fauteuil pure et son mari étaient là
j'étais plus embêté en tout cas ce qui
m'a plu dans cette image ou dans cette
danse est parole c'est qu'elle me voyait
comme un être érotique et comme un être
sexué et ça ça m'a beaucoup plu
et donc ce que je vous montrais à
travers ça c'est que le fauteuil roulant
peut être un formidable à 12 atout de
séduction
si on n'en a pas peur il ya aucune
raison
voilà et pour les messieurs que ça
intéresse
après ce top si vous le souhaitez je
vous donnerai quelques conseils
puis est venue la douleur la douleur
physique douleur physique intense
douleur physique
le résultat de quinze années passées à
la tête d'une entreprise de cinq
personnes
quinze années passées à vivre a rigolé à
faire la fête à avoir des projets à
partir dans tous les sens ça fait un peu
n'importe quoi et à s'éclater et la
douleur est arrivée la douleur qui vous
envahissent la douleur qui ne vous
quitte plus jamais la douleur qui vous
brûle la douleur qui vous transpercent
celle qui étreint et quand l'abc que je
voyais à l'époque m'a demandé de
remercier ma douleur tous les matins en
me levant je dois vous avouer que je me
suis demandé s'il n'était pas un peu
cintrée mais j'ai réfléchi et la chose
et je me suis dit qu'est ce que peut
m'apporter le fait de remercier ma
douleur
ce que j'ai commencé à faire tous les
matins en me levant et je me suis rendu
compte qu en remerciant ma douleur et
bien j'arrivais à prendre du recul
j'arrivais à prendre de la sagesse et
j'arrivais à prendre de l'élévation et
donc je me suis rendu compte aussi d'une
chose c'est que j'avais les capacités
nous avons des capacités énormes pour
affronter les choses et nous avons une
capacité d'adaptation qui est absolument
phénoménale et je me suis rendu compte
que mon cerveau était capable
d'encaisser cette douleur et que mon
cerveau était capable de se remettre au
niveau de ma douleur pour pouvoir
l'accepter et pour pouvoir la surmonter
et ce qui est assez étonnant c'est que
finalement le seul moment où je n'ai
absolument plus mal
je ne me sens absolument plus ma douleur
c'est quand je fais de la photo je vous
enlève cette photo parce que je sens que
vous perturbe
patrick tu as cette discrétion
cette humilité cette finesse qui
caractérise l'intelligence des mains
sont le prolongement de celle ci avec
elle chaque jour tu me soulage d'une
douleur étourdissante et puis dans la
douleur il ya la douleur partagée avec
ceux et celles qui étaient à mes côtés
lors de mon accident et marie ma petite
amie de l'époque marie ce soir là le 9
novembre 84 je devais venir te chercher
à la gare je ne suis jamais venu
tu vas retrouver paraplégique dans un
hôpital quelques mois après cet accident
la vie nous a séparés et puis avec le
temps nous nous sommes retrouvé
conscient d'avoir vécu ensemble quelque
chose d'exceptionnel mari m'a répondu
j'en fis merci beaucoup pour tout
j'aurais aimé montrer de tsunami le
gouffre qui s'est ouvert sous mes pieds
la fin d'un monde qui s'est produit
lorsque j'ai appris que tu ne
remarcherait sans doute plus comment
l'exprimer dans photo je t'aime
profondément et puis il ya aussi la
douleur je dirais je parlerai pas de
douleur d'ailleurs je parlerais plutôt
d'attention des gens qui vivent avec moi
depuis depuis quelques années ceux qui
doivent m'accompagner me voir me
débattre avec ma douleur avec mes
questions d'avenir et qui n'ont peut
être pas encore compris que ce que nous
vivons ensemble nous apportera à tous
une force incroyable
sophie supportant toi l'énergie pour
nous tenir debout et m'accompagner dans
la vie tu as la foi l'élégance et la
féminité l'équilibré et la stabilité
chaque jour dans l'arène tel le
gladiateur du combat grâce à téter des
attaques détermination est ce une
épreuve de force
ce qui est intéressant avec les
problèmes de santé c'est que ça vous
apprend l'humilité
vous développez une sorte de
fragilité qui vous fait devenir plus
conscients et donc ça vous permet
d'avoir une plus grande ouverture
d'esprit et d'être plus tourné vers les
autres
alors oui je suis différent et cela fait
bien longtemps que je ne souffre plus du
regard des autres
car je cultive cette différence car pour
moi les nourricière et singulière jean
pierre merci mon oncle pour ce jour vous
emmerde franc et massif
ce bras d'honneur est un hommage à tous
les cons à ceux qui pensent que la
différence est dérangeante
alors c'est vrai je me suis vite assumer
en fauteuil roulant car je me suis rendu
compte que mon fauteuil était un
amplificateur relationnel je me suis
rendu compte que c'était un mode de
communication non verbale très puissant
et je me suis rendu compte que c'était
presque une forme d'expression
je m'en suis rendu compte aussi puisque
j'ai pas mal voyagé et à l'étranger ça a
suscité pas mal de belles rencontres
mais aussi de l'étonnement et
l'admiration
monsieur le ministre chef de la
diplomatie espagnole depuis 2004 vous
portez en vous tous les faits tous les
messages du monde excusez moi vous
portez en vous tous les messages de paix
du monde cela fait de vous un homme
profondément bon est rare miguel octobre
2010 tout un symbole j'arrive à madrid
tu viens de tourner le dos à son siège
alors c'est vrai que je n'aime pas non
plus enfin je n'aime pas les cases je
n'aime pas qu'on veuille absolument me
faire rentrer dans un dans une petite
boîte et je vous racontais juste deux
histoires rapide et rigolote qui font
que on s'aperçoit que les gens fauteuil
roulant ou les gens qui ont un handicap
pour les gens qui sont différents en
fait on veut absolument les mettre dans
quelque chose se trouve que j'ai une
grosse voiture allemande break dont je
ne citerai pas la marque
quinze jours je me gare à quimper sur
une place handicapée je me gare à une ma
voiture j'arrive joue ma porte je vais
pour descendre en fauteuil est là et une
dame qui me saute dessus et qui me dit
les places handicapées c'est pas pour
les chiens
ce à quoi je réponds mais je ne
comprends pas madame on ne peut pas être
beau gosse avoir une grosse voiture et
être handicapé pouf pouf aurait dit
pierre desproges
ou alors je crois que je vais vous
raconter la deuxième sur le sur le sur
le stationnement parce que ça m'arrivait
ya cinq jours
c'est vraisemblablement la même mais
c'est assez rigolo c'est un petit gars
jouve mashov ma fenêtre et il me dit un
monsieur tu sais que c'est la douane
ces contrôles de papiers ici monsieur
hockey mais j'ai dit mais je me garer
sur une place handicapée 10 et givet
pourquoi tu veux des papiers ils
contrôlent d'accord ok mais je dis
pourquoi il me dit bah t'as pas droites
de gamme et c'est une place handicapée
je dis ouais je sais je dis regarde le
fauteuil car à côté de moi alors je vous
larvée refait parce que je n'ai pas bien
le jeune homme le jeune homme me dit
c'est contrôle de douane est ce que vous
pouvez me présenter vos papiers je lui
dis non je les présente pas parce que
j'ai droit de me garer la ligue ne t'a
pas droit j pourquoi j'ai pas droit dit
a vu là qu'est ce que tu as bah je lui
dis ouais et regarde j'ai un fauteuil oh
[ __ ] me dis que la boulette let
c'est pas possible comme quoi des codes
on est handicapé
donc si on est handicapé on est
malheureux si on est handicapé on est
dans le besoin
et si on est handicapé on n'a pas de
travail c'est des codes ses les cases et
j'ai horreur de ça donc pour finir
j'aimerais vous dire que effectivement
pour moi la différence est une richesse
une formidable richesse qui vous permet
de de comprendre qu' on peut aller vers
des gens qui sont différents qui ont une
autre culture qui ont un autre mode de
fonctionnement et que pour moi ça c'est
quelque chose d'absolument essentiel et
puis pour vous pour pour terminer je
voudrais vous dire que ce fauteuil
ma compagne dans la vie depuis 30 ans et
mon compagnon de vie depuis 30 ans si je
peux dire qu'il m'a fait connaître le
pire
je crois aussi pouvoir dire qui m'a
sauvée de la médiocrité
parce que tous les jours il m'oblige à
m'élever et agrandir et puis
je voudrais vous le dire sincèrement
cette expérience mérite d'être vécue
sincèrement cette expérience mérite
d'être vécue et puis parce que je lui
voue un amour incommensurable et une
tendresse incommensurable je voudrais
dédier ce dock à mon fils achille que
j'aime tendrement achille tu es mon
coeur ma joie ma passion mon courage
avec toi le voyage de surprises en
émotion brésil terre de partage rio
avril 2010 merci